[Music]
all right welcome back to pft live there
is the bio of our next guest super bowl
17 champion my god i remember that like
it was yesterday the john riggins run to
daylight the win over the miami dolphins
joe theismann the quarterback of that
team also the mvp of the nfl the
following year with one of the highest
powered offenses the nfl has ever seen
here he is joe theisman joe good morning
how are you pal
morning guys uh listen i heard you
talking about you know chris's dad
phil and i had the opportunity to win a
super bowl but the one thing that i
admire so much and i watch your dad all
the time my buddy um he has his dark
glasses now i thought i'd just whoa
i was gonna i was gonna wear the glasses
like phil now too
don't do that man don't do it you know
you still got young eyes you're good
you're way more handsome than him don't
even worry you're good way too kind
way too kind thanks guys joe speaking of
things you wear on your face when i
think joe theisman the first thing i
think of is that single bar face mask
the last
non-kicker or punter to ever wear the
single bar face mask and i was looking
at some pictures during break that
really did not afford you much
protection how did you manage to go your
whole career with this one bar just kind
of like right across the middle of your
face between your nose and your mouth
actually stupidity probably was a
driving force um you know i've had seven
broken noses and you know dental uh
cosmetic dentistry is a great thing for
my front teeth got those knocked out by
byron hunt
uh i just when i it's really crazy when
i hand it off the two bars bothered me
and you know chris you know it we're
finicky when it comes to the quarterback
position i didn't wear anything on my
right arm i didn't wear a wristband i
wore an elbow pad on my left but nothing
on my right the way the ball feels in
your hand the way you see things
we're probably the most finicky people
in the game when it comes to that and so
for me it just bothered me plus there's
something else nobody really knows and i
don't share it a lot billy kilmer and
sonny jurgensen both wore single bars
now what would i have looked like if i
wore a double bar so you know a little
bit of peer pressure but more from a
visual standpoint
oh that's great and it it always sends
the message to me the guy that wears the
single bar is the guy who would go bobby
lane and wear no
no face mask at all if the rule didn't
require it's like you're gonna make me
wear one i'm gonna wear the smallest
possible face mask that i can well you
know mike what's really interesting when
i was in high school i first started
many years ago my face mask was
plexiglas and it sort of it went around
this way and then widened in the middle
a little bit more so that was right
where they just started putting face
masks on helmets
joe uh i'm i'm intrigued with the the
aspect of your story is a lot like the
kansas city chiefs we got this year
repeat super bowl champion
coming into the super bowl playing a
team that you played in the regular
season
and beat you guys beat the raiders in
the regular season before you played
them in the super bowl just dive into
that and kind of like the mental
gymnastics of what it was like for you
guys preparing and you know how the game
played out and just how you think it was
all affected by that regular season
matchup well the first one we played in
chris we had the opportunity to only
have one week so everything sort of
stayed on on schedule
the second one super bowl 18 we had a
two-week period of time to get ready and
truthfully we had a great practice on
thursday i felt really sharp on thursday
but as the week went on friday saturday
i didn't quite have that same edge that
i had before now that was before we had
bye weeks in the national football
league guys are used to having a couple
weeks off now the biggest thing is about
the players that haven't been there
number one take care of yourself the
covet 19 scenario just hangs over this
game for another three four days once we
get through that then we can take a deep
breath but who's going to be affected
and how will it affect us but it's the
mental part of it the preparation's
there i mean they could play tomorrow
both teams could but the mental part of
it is how do you deal with getting
yourself ready to play really what
bounce to the game of your life
you're the mvp in 1983 in 1982 when the
team won the super bowl strike shortened
season nine games and i said
i've been trying to figure this out for
years now how in the hell
does your kicker end up being the league
mvp
in 1982
you know you know mike if it was if it
was a longer season it may not have
happened but mark made so many key kicks
for us during that shortened period of
time i mean you know we only like say we
only played nine games we were eight and
one but i'd say three of those were won
by mark mosley and when you look at the
percentage of wins that kick that he
contributed to for us it made an awful
lot of sense for him to be a kicker
and you look at games today i mean tom
brady's first three rings come on field
goal kicks so when you really break down
games uh about a third maybe even a
little bit more than that are decided by
three points or less
and then mo you know i really without
john and mark those were two very key
people for us to wear a championship
ring your your head coach joe gibbs i
feel like is the least talked about
great coach of all time
uh i don't know why that is i mean i
guess he's got a little under the radar
persona about him but like to you joe
theism when i say joe gibbs like what's
the first you know one or two things
that come to your mind
his his
red zone abilities the way he could
operate in the red zone i mean i i've
told joe this on different occasions
watching games and i love to watch games
i said you ought to give a clinic to
coaches out there on how to operate in
the red zone because we managed to get
the ball in the end zone 1983 we were
the highest scoring team in the history
of football at that time
and we were average almost 35 points a
game and that was at a time when it was
a different we huddled uh you didn't
have the hurry up offense you have now
right and so it was the efficiency with
which we ran and the other thing was his
creativity joe would always come up with
something during the week to pique our
interest something we would run during
the game that you got to that moment and
say hey this is cool i can't wait till
he calls it right
you know i was reading a book recently
joe where uh joe gibbs was consulting
with rex ryan about 10 years ago and
that issue came up the idea of
specifically inventing plays
for individual players and that would
get them even more invested in
everything that joe was trying to do
because he knew the player knew there's
a play just for me that we're going to
use down near the end zone and we're
going to score a touchdown on it
exactly and the thing is is too mike
what he does
is he fit the system was a system it was
a too tight end offense it was sort of
innovative at that time and and joe
really developed it as we went on but
what he did is he took the system and
then he found the people that he wanted
to fit in certain situations and then he
would design the plays to take advantage
of that person he gave us opportunity
after opportunity to execute and get the
job done and if you didn't they'd find
somebody else it's no different than it
really is today
except that now you're locked in
economically sometimes to keep people
around and you just can't do anything
back then there was no you didn't have a
salary cap we didn't have free agency i
mean you had to play your rear end off
for the guy behind you was going to get
a chance to play so whenever the
opportunity came we managed to
capitalize it we had a great bunch of
guys too and and chris you know this as
well as anybody it really boils down to
the locker room the way the guys care
about one another the way the guys
communicate uh that locker room
should and did belong to us in all the
years i played for coach gibbs the six
years i played for him i saw him in our
locker room five times
he let us he let us run that part of the
of the of the football team and that's
where you really build camaraderie
there's a problem we handled it there's
an issue we handled it we had fun with
one another and you know we used to bust
on everybody all the time but it was
just good fun i call ourselves the
characters with character
well it's the way football should be and
uh you know i i of course have enjoyed
watching your career when you played
watching highlights you're slick you're
an nfl mvp
i want joe this perspective of
patrick mahomes and what we're seeing
right now out of this guy what makes him
so unique to you yeah go ahead
he's i'm sorry he's magical he uh he's
he's started you know you see the brett
favre in him the the smile on his face
the bouncing around the leadership he
showed last week when things went south
against buffalo running out on the field
making sure it was funny he was making
sure that the players stayed on the
sidelines but he specifically went after
tariq and say look man you're way too
important don't you get involved in this
thing right because you know he was
ready to go uh his leadership skills his
athletic skills a lot of guys can throw
the ball at different angles like he
does from sidearm to over the top
but for him it seems so natural i mean
when he plays the position he plays it
physically in a way that is fun to watch
but he plays it mentally in a way that
he understands the entire game and
they're two very distinctly different
things doesn't matter how good arm you
have doesn't matter how quick you are
doesn't matter any but how do you play
the game how do you call a play when you
get it down in distance what are you
going to do and of course there's always
that great marriage between the play
caller and the quarterback you see it
down in new orleans with drew and sean
and i think with andy and patrick it's
the same thing plus patrick had the
benefit and this can't be understated to
work with alex smith for a year
really i think taught him how to prepare
how to become a professional how to
learn the game and that's invaluable
when you're young and then you develop
your own style after that but the
foundation was something that alex
helped him build
all right joe we talked about the
playing days i got a question an
important one from your broadcasting
days i'm going to take you back 15 years
to tampa the site of this year's super
bowl your washington football team
versus the tampa bay buccaneers and this
guy chris
runs into the end zone scores a
touchdown and he throws the ball in the
direction of the pirate ship now
he claims paul mcguire said this now
paul mcguire we know like budweiser beer
and stuff like that but i'm just saying
he said it on there chris
please let me finish please counselor
chris claims
that he threw the ball into one of the
holes on one of the cannons
can you confirm or deny
i can confirm that he did yes and if
paul mcguire
if paul mcguire made that observation
you know it had to absolutely be true
right because
you know what it's like going to
production meetings right
there he is look at him just ready to go
when when paul when paul went into a
production meeting he only took one note
he took one note so i asked him one day
i said paul why do you why do you only
just take one note in these production
meetings he said how are you supposed to
listen to what people are saying when
you're writing and i thought basically i
could do both but um paulie he was very
observant i mean
mike patrick paul mcguire and having the
opportunity to work with those two guys
at espn was just so much fun it was the
early years of broadcasting at espn when
it came to professional football and it
was just a ton of fun again it's like a
mini locker room we'd go out to dinner
on friday night saturday night and just
really the camaraderie is i think what
makes the booth really yeah but you know
joe you you talked about alex smith
it i mean i got to ask about him because
i was holding my breath all year
watching him play
i really was but just talk about
how shocked were you that you actually
saw him on the football field this year
after an injury that was very similar to
your own injury
honestly i wasn't surprised because over
the last two years we've communicated a
lot we've talked a lot i've watched his
progress two years ago in training camp
you know he still had that thing on his
foot
we would kneel down in the locker room
in the weight room and just throw the
ball back and forth a little bit i'm i
really wanted to stay close to him i
i've said this before and i mean it from
the bottom of my heart elizabeth his
wife i know is his biggest fan i'm
number two nobody rooted harder for him
to come back in the beginning i gave it
a 75 25 chance that he wouldn't but then
i saw his dedication i mean he got a
letter from the secretary of state to be
able to go to the center down in texas
where they work on the troops i mean he
did everything he could and when you
think of his history the guy carried
rocks underwater to train
so i mean what else was he not able to
accomplish and just the fact that he
when he went out against the ramps and
aaron donald jumped on his back
i held my breath oh no please don't let
anything happen and it didn't i i think
it also worked that way for alex i think
in his mind it's like you know what i
can do this again and then he just got
better and better of course at the end
of the season this year had the calf
issue and just the fact that he's out
there i mean he should without question
be the comeback player of the year i
don't even think there's anybody close
i think the moment he got on the field
yeah makes him the comeback player of
the year um joe tell us what you have
going on with mid liminal
med limit was an interesting company
what it is we examine employers of
employees medical bills and you know
with this pandemic going on and
everybody trying to
people trying to save money in a certain
way it's like it's really like a health
savings program what mid limital does is
they put the bills your medical bills
into an hcat system what it is is this
system examines the bills and then
nurses and health care experts go over
it and they really try and save the
employer self-insured employers to try
and save them money and that's what it
really boils down to is how can you find
ways to put money back into your company
to be able to save yourself it's a
collaboration
between like i say nurses and then
healthcare experts but it also is an
opportunity to be able to
work with the employers to be able to
try and save them money and you can go
to medliminal.com and find out more
about us and who we are and what we do
but it it doesn't cost anything if you
don't find anything in the medical bills
then it doesn't cost you anything that's
the most important thing
and i promise you this guys
if we were to sit down as
just employees employers employees
people and try and read a medical bill
you can't
you have no idea what the charges are so
what they are is really i sort of call
them a watchdog they want to make sure
that the charges are correct that you're
being charged for and make sure that
it's it's not being overpaid so it's uh
i've been with the company as far as a
spokesman for the last couple of years
it makes so much sense to be able to try
especially now is where can we find a
little bit more money where can we find
a little bit more savings
and like i said uh medlimital the
med it's m-e-d-l-i-m-i-n-a-l
dot com and you can get all more
information there
i got a great idea for reducing medical
bills
don't wear a single bar face mask don't
wear a single bar face mask that's the
key all right hey great stuff great
seeing you great talking to you all the
best we'll talk to you again down the
road joe
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports